[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv soixante dix
huit pour cette nouvelle édition du 7 8
politiques consacrées à chaque semaine
aux élections départementales et
régionales lé scrutin qui se déroule
dans quelques jours maintenant dernière
ligne droite pour les candidats avant de
parler de leurs propositions leur
dernier point de programme parlons de
ces deux assemblées leur rôle ne sont
pas toujours très bien connu par la
population après avoir détaillé le rôle
de la région il ya quelques semaines
nous revenons aujourd'hui sur le rôle du
département explications signé eléonore
sinoquet depuis la loi notre voter en
2015 les départements de nouvelles
compétences
elles forment quatre grandes familles le
principal volet de l'action du
département concerne le social aide
sociale à l'enfance qui s'occupe des
enfants maltraités mais aussi de la pmi
la protection maternelle et infantile
sur le suivi des grossesses et des
jeunes enfants agrément pour les
adoptions crèche ou encore maison de
retraite
il assure également un revenu minimum
aux personnes éligibles à l'allocation
personnes âgées et personnes handicapées
pour les actifs il permet l'accès au
revenu de solidarité active ainsi que
l'accompagnement vers le retour à
l'emploi
le département entretient les 1500 75 km
de routes départementales développent de
nouveaux axes de circulation et
participe aux grands projets
d'infrastructures dans les yvelines la
ligne de tramway t6 qui passe par vélizy
et va jusqu à viroflay ou encore le
projet eole pour rapprocher la gare
saint-lazare de mantes la jolie par
exemple dans le secteur de l'éducation
le département des yvelines s'occupe de
145 collège public entretient
équipements numériques cantine personnel
technique et même le financement de la
construction de nouveaux établissements
dernière grande compétence du
département l'aménagement du territoire
qui englobe plusieurs sujets cela va du
soutien aux communes pour des projets
d'aménagement la gestion de l'eau la
protection des espaces naturels
sensibles
ils sont au nombre de 64 dans les
yvelines l'aménagement de sentiers de
randonnée aire de pique nique piste
cyclable au financement du service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
le département toi enfin garantir
l'accès au très haut débit sur son
territoire ajoutez à cela le département
partage aussi des compétences avec la
région le tourisme la culture ou encore
les animations sportives
si compétences au total qui montre
l'importance du tandem entre les deux
collectivités pour le territoire et vous
pouvez également revoir notre reportage
sur les compétences régionales sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile la campagne électorale du premier
tour qui touche donc à sa fin pour les
départementales dans les yvelines la
majorité sortante fait un dernier point
sur ses propositions pour le prochain
mandat 21 une proposition pour autant de
cantons nicolas landry l'innovation la
qualité de vie le développement durable
et la protection les priorités des
candidats ensemble pour les yvelines
dans le cadre des élections
départementales un programme pour les
six prochaines années dans la continuité
des actions mises en oeuvre lors du
dernier mandat
on est partagé entre les missions
fondamentales qui sont les nôtres je
pense en particulier à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
notre mission aussi avec les communes
donc d'accompagner les communes je pense
aux bonus environnemental
et puis notre mission aussi de faire que
l'on vive mieux sur ce territoire
c'est aussi construire quinze nouveaux
collèges en bois et en matériaux éco
responsable financées jusqu'à 100 euros
les activités culturelles et sportives
des jeunes de 11 à 18 ans ou encore
crédit villages d'enfants pour faciliter
l'intégration des enfants pris en charge
par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
les enfants qui sortent de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance compas tous les
moyens de s'intégrer
heureusement dans la société il faut
donc nous nous améliorons les pour cela
nous pensons que il faut sortir de la
logique de foyers pour rentrer dans une
logique de village qui soit dans une
dimension plus familial le plus petit
plus humaine sans doute l'équipe menée
par pierre bédier souhaite amplifier la
collaboration avec les hauts de seine
une volonté aussi de poursuivre les
investissements dans les infrastructures
une participation financière des deux
départements pourraient être engagées
pour la ligne 18
nous sommes tout à fait prêts à prendre
comme nous l'avons fait pour les hommes
avec nos voisins et amis du 92 à prendre
une partie du financement pour faire
versailles croatie au total ce sont 21
actions qui sont proposées aux yvelinois
dans le programme des candidats ensemble
pour les yvelines pour rappel les
élections départementales se tiennent
les dimanches 20 et 27 juin
dans le canton de trappes à six binômes
se présente la gauche part unie et
derrière le maire génération de trappes
à lire rabais et la communiste
anne-marie bouquet et il est également
opposé au binôme du centre droit du
maire de la verrière et de la deuxième
adjointe d'elancourt
on a besoin d'avoir une pluralité
d'opinions qui s'exprime par ce qu'il y
a des hommes et des femmes écologistes
de gauche dans notre département il leur
faut des élus pour porter leur parole
est aiguillonné la majorité être capable
de dénoncer ces contradictions être
capable également de dire quand l'action
du département est insuffisante
que ce soit en matière de solidarité je
vous le disais d'éducation de transition
écologique à prendre à bras le corps
face à l'urgence climatique et sur tous
ces sujets l'action du département est
insuffisante l'action à mon avis du
département doit se concentrer sur les
problèmes concrets de la vie de tous les
jours des yvelinois
je vais vous en citer plusieurs la
question de la santé par exemple dans
notre département nous devons nous
investir d'autant plus que nous avons
une université je vous le rappelle une
faculté de médecine qui forment des
centaines de professionnels de santé
accompagnons ces étudiants en
particulier ceux qui sont originaires
des yvelines mais pas que pour leur dire
nous sommes capables de vous accompagner
sur plusieurs années et en contrepartie
on vous demande de vous investir sur le
territoire pendant dix ans par exemple
pendant 15 ans et vous savez qu'une fois
qu'un médecin s'installe
s'il est bien là où il s'installe en
général il restera toute sa carrière
une des compétences du département les
français ne le savent pas assez
le département est compétent en matière
de handicap notamment ce sont des
maisons départementales des personnes
handicapées qui reconnaissent les droits
des personnes et les accompagnent et
bien notre département est un mauvais
élève
les délais de traitement des demandes
dans notre département sont très longs
ils sont trois fois plus long que les
départements les plus vertueux nous
devons nous réorganiser
administrativement mettre les moyens
humains nécessaires pour accompagner les
demandeurs et monter les dossiers et
veiller à répondre dans des délais très
courts aux demandes légitimes que
peuvent formuler des yvelinois en
situation d'handicap
à noter que l'un des cinq binômes
présentée par le parti présidentiel dans
les yvelines par la république en marche
se trouve également sur ce canton de
trappes qui concerne donc les communes
de trappes bien évidemment d'elancourt
et de la verrière partons pour le canton
de plaisir à présent quatre binômes sont
engagés et la gauche par également unis
écoutez leur candidat
[Musique]
c'est la suite naturelle des choses
quand on est déjà élu municipal
atteindre les départementales c'est
c'est quelque chose qui qui se trouve
dans une autre sphère est très
intéressante et puis de toute façon il
n'ya sur les 21 cantons il n'y a pas de
gauche représentés donc il était
indispensable qu'une équipe se présente
pour le canton plaisir une équipe de
gauche unie écologiste et sociale la
raison pour laquelle on a souhaité
s'engager avec annie joël prix us ni
gérard les vides
ludivine de gand c'est qu'en fait on est
élus municipaux aujourd'hui et en tant
qu'élus municipaux on a une vision sur
ce que fait le département quel est son
rôle qu'est ce qui la porte mais aussi
quels sont ces manquements
pour nous il doit être un échelon proche
des gens un échelon qui qui laisse sa
chance à chacun d'avoir un accès égal
aux services publics écologie aller
solidarité et la démocratie et à partir
de ces trois axes qui sont donc notre
socle on a au regard des laits manque
justement et les projets qui pourraient
être portées sur le département et de
manière transversale c'est à dire sur
sur la santé la sécurité les collèges on
aimerait recruter des médecins
généralistes que le département puisse
donner les moyens
et puis l'autre l'autre idée c'est aussi
l'autre domaine c'est tout ce qui
concerne la sécurité et nous ne pouvons
pas voir et et appréhender la sécurité
sans prévention sur le canton de plaisir
se présente également sans étiquette
sandrine carneiro et christophe par an
pour le rassemblement national à guy
bonhomme et marie-louise marchetti et
pour le centre droite la liste sortante
celle de joséphine coleman ce berger et
de bertrand coquard autres cantons avant
d'évoquer les régionales en île de
france celui du chesnay le conseiller
général sortant philippe brillault ne se
représente pas saoul
les couleurs de la majorité
présidentielle la majorité yvelinoise
pardon mais il figure en tant que
suppléant sur un ticket divers droite
menée par nicolas quillet et stéphane
michel écouter leurs propos recueillis
par justine brasier après sept années de
fonder ni nous pensons qu'il ya vraiment
tout 1 1
une action sociale à mener il faut
continuer à se mobiliser et l'action
sociale c'est le coeur du département
c'est le coeur de sa mission cette crise
doit être va encore avoir des effets et
nous devons être mobilisés pour aider
tous les habitants les commerces les
jeunes il y a beaucoup à faire
je n'accepte pas la position qui a été
prise dans notre département de donner
l'investiture à un maire qui ne soutient
pas valérie pécresse à la région par
exemple et donc c'est aussi une des
raisons de mon engagement mon engagement
sera axée principalement sur
l'enseignement sur les collèges est sûre
et sur les infrastructures les routes
les routes par exemple puisque puisque
c'est un un sujet que je connais bien
puisque j'ai été j'étais ingénieur
territorial sur les routes
départementales notamment
[Musique]
on a bien vu la baisse des subventions
même presque la disparition de beaucoup
de subventions au sport et à la culture
donc pour nous c'est un point important
mois les associations c'est cher à mon
coeur et je pense que c'est vraiment le
coeur des villes c'est ça qui fait le
vivre ensemble
les subventions c'est quelque chose
d'important mais il ya aussi les pelles
et pmi en matière d'enfance qui font un
peu défaut en ce moment et notre volonté
c'est d'essayer de remettre en ordre ses
points de vue là pour ce qui est de la
c5 louis du collège
c'est un projet qui devait voir le jour
à la rentrée prochaine qui finalement ne
verra pas le jour la rentrée prochaine
j'ai bien l'intention de m'investir à
fond et de vraiment travailler sur tous
ces dossiers comme le collège pasteur
comme bougival comme les infrastructures
à bailly donc voilà c'est vraiment
travailler avec les maires à 100% braves
pour faire avancer des dossiers au
niveau des départements
notre volonté c'est d'être en contact
direct avec les habitants et de l'or
entre guillemets rendre compte de nos de
nos actions et ça fait partie de nos
propositions de de mettre en place une
sorte de de perdre permanence vous nous
avez face à vous à 4 nous sommes quatre
sur l'affiché nous le resterons là c'est
à dire que il ya effectivement un binôme
titulaires qui sera élu mais le binôme
remplaçant ou suppléants sera toujours
présent et associés est associée au
travail
[Musique]
les régionales en ile-de-france et
valérie pécresse toujours en tête au
premier tour à gauche chaque formation
espère tirer son épingle du jeu être en
position de mener une liste d'union au
second tour écoutez clémentine autain
pour la france un soumises elles
aspirent à un changement radical du mode
de gestion de la région
je souhaite qu'on ait un changement en
profondeur du modèle de développement de
la région pour avancer vers une
bifurcation sociale et écologique c'est
à dire que la région soit actrice de
l'économie et fasse en sorte qu'on est
con satisfasse les besoins de la
population avant tout et non pas les
besoins du monde financier et de la
concurrence internationale sans cesse
plus féroce prends un exemple la région
a soutenu le charles de gaulle express
qui est en train pour les riches qui va
de paris à roissy sans s'arrêter dans
aucune gare alors que pendant ce temps
là les gens galèrent dans le rer b qui
attend de la rénovation et la
modernisation est bien avec moi on
commencera toujours par satisfaire les
besoins de la population et donc en
l'occurrence en matière de transport qui
est une compétence très importante de la
région
on mettra le paquet sur la modernisation
des lignes propos recueillis par nos
confrères de radio sensations en ile de
france ce sont au total onze listes qui
se présentent en dehors des listes
traditionnelles 4 tentent de se faire
entendre auprès des électeurs avec des
propositions très différentes
astrid berges vers nous les présente en
ile de france 11 10 sont officiellement
déclarés pour les élections régionales
parmi elles quatre sont moins connus
sandro râteau et la tête de liste aux
élections j pour les yvelines menée par
le parti écologiste et antispécistes
révolution écologique pour le vivant
cegid évidemment de nous de mettre en
évidence le fait que les idées que nous
portons pour une écologie radicale ou
sociales antispécistes ont déjà refusé
au sein de la société civile ce que nous
voulons maintenant c'est les porter dans
le débat sur la scène politique donc
c'est l'idée si vous voulez d'une
écologie qui ne soit plus centré sur
l'humain mais qui insiste sur l'idée que
les autres êtres vivants ne sont pas des
ressources à notre disposition mais
possède une valeur en eux mêmes parmi
les idées fortes la création d'une
maison
régional des animaux ou encore la
suppression des subventions allouées aux
chasseurs autres listes autre objectif
ile-de-france pile d'europe est porté
par elvire ces cas dans les yvelines
ile-de-france il d'europe est un peu le
regroupement on va dire de c'est une
volonté de déclencheur renouvellement
politique la liste mobilise plusieurs
mouvements là c'est des mouvements
citoyens principalement et pro-européen
donc et puis aussi les membres de la
société civile comme moi les candidats
souhaitent la mise en place du rich et
de la convention citoyenne régionales
mais ils veulent aussi créer des maisons
de la parentalité et des femmes
autre mesure la création de parkings
gratuits à proximité des gares
franciliennes agir pour ne plus subir
c'est le nom de la liste conduite par
l'union des démocrates musulmans
français dans les yvelines c'est aïcha
ia qui est tête de liste
objectif donner la voix aux musulmans et
non musulmans qui ne se retrouvent plus
dans les partis traditionnels lutter
contre l'islamophobie mais aussi réduire
les déserts médicaux
marc de fouquières lui est tête de liste
yvelines pour france démocratie directe
une liste citoyenne qui permet à chacun
de s'exprimer de proposer des projets et
des idées
l'objectif lutter contre le manque de
transparence et redevenir acteur de la
démocratie c'est la fin de ce set 8
politique rendez-vous 19 heures dimanche
sur notre site internet
nos réseaux sociaux pour suivre les
premières tendances les résultats et les
premières réactions à lundi sur notre
antenne vous pourrez suivre l'émission
paf avec patrice carmouze qui recevra
les principaux responsables des
formations politiques
et puis édition spéciale de votre
journal dès 19h avec un résumé complet
du premier tour et tous les enjeux du
second aussi bien pour les régionales
que pour les départementales excellente
semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]